just you know my thing is this is I'm
with that
my issue is this is the shame around it
that's the problem with me whether you
are a person who's like you know
I don't want someone that's slept around
a lot whatever the case may be
it's the shame that we're attaching it
does not matter you make conscious poor
decisions and I'm not saying that
everybody's journey is the same I'm not
I'm not adding variables I'm adding
Tendencies and I'm adding your Resorts
so what do you resort to when push comes
to shove and at the end of the day that
is who your character is but why did why
does the why doesn't that but you can't
you can't sit here and make an excuse
for a person trying to do wrong and not
point at me do not point no no I was
just like I was just I wasn't I wasn't
it wasn't I believe nowhere near you
ability
under anything I believe in
accountability but I also to what point
hold on I believe in accountability
however I understand the process of
development and I understand the process
of really comprehension we're not going
to say a 14 year old's decision-making
skill is the same as a 25 year old's
decision-making skill no we're not going
to say because I don't give an excuse
for a 25 year old I I'm not giving an
excuse to a 14 year old I'm not giving
an excuse to a 10 year old do you see
what I'm saying when we look at brain in
terms of brain development we can't in
2022 say because you're 14 you have a
clear understanding of logic and
consequence as an adult this is this is
this is the choice you make so if you're
14 15 16 you make a choice that's the
consequence and like we're so used to
being bailed out of every bad decision
and we're so used to not having
consequences that we want to tell the
men well you should understand us this
is our journey and
it's like like it's just like another
way to say [ __ ] if you notice your
decision own it yeah like there are
there are men that I've talked to they
sold like like they've had a criminal
past and they don't say this was my
journey or whatever they said I was
young I was dumb I did that and we own
it yes
they know the consequence that comes
with it they don't say well everyone
around me shouldn't judge and like and I
shouldn't go to jail I should never go
to jail for committing a crime but you
know what I had no food for seven days
your honor I didn't know what it's like
to eat so I went and I sold some drugs
to get some money but you know what I
was 21 and my frontal lobe wasn't really
working and you know what that you know
what else life threw me curveballs and I
tried to make lemons and I made orange
juice but don't tell me that I'm wrong I
just want to say because it's real funny
right now because I hear you laughing a
lot okay have you ever been homeless
have I ever been homeless yes have you
ever been without food for seven days
without without food for seven days yeah
um I have been homeless for a little bit
I was living in a car
um
but it was my choice
I wanted to experience it I was like I'm
gonna damn life but this is but that's
but this is what I'm saying
I've never gone without food for seven
days but to be fair neither have most
women in America because half of women
are overweight oh [ __ ] okay anyways go
ahead
because that's not even funny it's not
funny when because I've been homeless
okay with two kids okay
I've been married and I've been in an
abusive relationship
okay
none of that is funny
it's not funny at all and if there's
women out there that need to find food
because they haven't ate in seven days
and they need to do whatever they need
to do they gotta do what they got to do
that wasn't my personal experience but
it's like
this is the problem when you have
conversations with people and everyone
is like oh this happened to you
that's crazy your consequences this and
that it's like you've never been in a
position
but I have wait wait hold on wait but I
have
I was homeless not for seven days longer
yeah you know what I was the kid I was
your child with a young parent with
nobody to help
I made poor decisions I suffered from
them I don't blame my mom I don't blame
my grandmother and my family I don't
blame the younger version of me I don't
try to look for an excuse at the end of
the day I did wrong okay and that's what
people need to understand [ __ ] so yeah
because of your actions no no [ __ ] your
trauma if you do wrong you take what
comes with it and you take it on the
chin and you wear it with a smile you
can have a good reason I'm not gonna
call it an excuse you can have a good
reason but you need to understand that
it's still wrong and then you also have
to understand that the world outside
will always demon as wrong even though
you deemed it as a necessity and that's
the point that's the line you have to
draw if you got to do what you got to do
to survive I'm not knocking it but you
got to understand what comes with it see
I have a mother
shout out to miss Batista who didn't
sell her body for money she acquired
three degrees
she acquired so many degrees that she
technically could have a PhD okay and
she did that while we were living in a
car
so when I see women that decide to out
into
selling their bodies
it's like that's not an excuse for me
now I'm not saying I'm part sorry I'm
I'm not saying
I'm not saying that you don't gotta do
what you gotta do and I'm not knocking
what you gotta do
all we're saying is you still gotta take
what comes with it regardless of how you
feel about it that's all it is and all
I'm saying and you may not share that
and that's okay what I'm saying is I
look at it from a different perspective
I don't look at it from that ice cold
perspective I view things with a
different lens I view it with compassion
and I understand that you may be like
pull yourself up by your bootstrap or
I've never experienced it and I'll view
it from an abstract perspective and just
get over it which often people do when
they don't live through it I just don't
view it that way so what I'm saying is I
just don't view it in that harsh way so
if a woman
I don't have to personally agree with a
woman having sex with a lot of women I
don't actually I mean sex with a lot of
men sorry always be both or whatever
these days you never know you know on a
personal note I don't however I don't
also view it from a judge mental
perspective
I understand that right but
we you are the reasons why the world is
so judgmental man's homeless he just has
to get a job like there's nothing
stopping her but if a woman is homeless
she just has to get a job it's the same
thing so if she chooses to do only fans
or do sex work she made a choice when
she could have done the same thing the
men do we said we're equal right we have
only fans but not not I think it's not
at the same rate you know you know who
wants to do you know what my thing is
okay but here's the thing I don't I
don't care what people do I genuinely
don't care if someone says I'm someone
else but listen listen let me finish let
me finish I don't care what people do so
if you want to go do only fans like that
that's fine but my my issue is when
women shame men when they complain about
the consequence because men say I don't
want a hoe and they say well you should
be understanding and the men say you
know what I actually have this standard
I don't want that that's like that's a
[ __ ] sorry I'm not dating [ __ ] then we
shame them but like that's my issue
I agree let's not shame people that's
what I'm trying to say no no no no no no
actually sorry sorry let me let me cry
correct ma'am if I may correct so let's
not shame people now bring back shame
not bring back shame that's what I'm
trying to say then you're trying to work
into a world of non
none non-categories
it is because at the end of the day how
do I decipher tell me if you're telling
me not to shame which I'm not shaming
I'm categorizing we then we just don't
suit so if you Rico say hey I'm not okay
with a woman that's been with 10 20
women okay great and I'm like hey I've
been with multiple people and this is
who I am right and I want X Y and Z it's
oh you I don't have to shame you for
wanting what you want and you don't have
to shame me my thing is okay it's like
why do you have because the question the
actual question well we're disagreeing
about is why do women have to lie yeah
okay and my thing is if we keep
um
telling women that having a 20 body
count or 30 or 40 it's like oh my God
you're a [ __ ] they're never going to
tell you the truth it's like why would
they tell you the truth when every time
you're calling them a hoe you're calling
them a [ __ ] telling them they're never
gonna get married they're never gonna do
this they're never gonna do that like
why what is the point of that I could
know I could know a hoe and be like
congratulations you know I hope it works
out for you that is your choice that is
what she wants to do I'm not going to
sit here and be like oh my God you never
gonna get married because you slept with
20 people oh my God this is going to
happen to you oh my God this is going to
happen to you because to be honest with
you it's like Aaron says what you eat
don't make me [ __ ] it's not my business
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible